seront cesari professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université d'arras
spécialiste des états unis bonsoir
monsieur ses amis merci d'être avec nous
thomas bonnet ou la question ça pourrait
peut-être faire changer les
règlementations cette sombre affaire
dont évidemment qui a fait parler
puisqu'il s'agit d'un acteur célèbre qui
a qui apportez donc ce coup de feu ça
peut selon vous va m'en aboutir à
quelque chose c'est peine perdue alors
en californie oui peut-être dans la
mesure où que vous savez la législation
varient selon les états et effectivement
le les élus de californie je pense
notamment à la sénatrice dianne
feinstein qui va bientôt se retirer
maintenant ont toujours été en pointe
sur la réglementation des armes à feu
est effectivement comme la loi concernée
concernerait avant tout les studios
hollywoodiens ça relève d'un droit local
donc ça serait possible en revanche à un
niveau fédéral c'est plus difficile
parce que on est dans l'aude ont fait
dans une mesure qui ne relèverait pas
delà de la conciliation budgétaire donc
il faudrait une majorité de 60 et vous
savez qu'elle est très difficile à
obtenir en ce moment qu'est ce qui
coince sur pour élargir ce débat sur les
armes aux états unis ce sont tout
simplement les mentalités des américains
qui veulent tout simplement continuer à
garder la rame ou c'est ce fameux lobby
dont on parle souvent l'année rires
d'ailleurs un des acteurs hollywoodiens
charlton heston était très en pointe sur
sur les défenses des armes il ya le
second amendement qui de la constitution
qui dit que deux comme une milice est un
droit d' est un droit essentiel une
milice de deux citoyens le le port des
armes ne sera pas ne sera pas interdit
enfin je paraphrase et que le talent de
tameghza la tête alors à partir de ça en
2008 la cour suprême a estimé que le
début de la phrase est relatif à la
milice était une simple clause de style
qui introduisait la proposition est
essentielle à savoir le droit des
citoyens quels qu'ils soient à avoir des
armes mais il ya toute une école qui et
c'est assez logique d'ailleurs qui dit
que non c'est le droit de porter des
armes est relatif à l'existence d'une
milice effectivement logiquement s'il
n'y avait pas de relation entre les deux
pourquoi avoir mis le début de phrase
est donc là évidemment comme commune
comme il ya belle lurette cas par la
garde nationale il ya plus de milices à
proprement parler on pourrait très bien
eux légiférer mais là ça supposait
d'aller contre un arrêt de la cour
suprême de 2008 d'avoir une majorité de
60 c'est lourd or les américains selon
les chiffres en tout cas nous
fournissent la suisse mot larmes
surveillants ils auraient en moyenne 120
armes à feu pour 100 habitants aux états
unis en ne comptant que la requérir
détenue par par des civils c'est sa part
m c'est énorme effectivement c'est une
proportions colossales par rapport au
reste du monde cela dit les gars de la
possession d'armes est en fait
autant content qu'on sache le fait d'une
minorité de la population mais des gens
qui sont véritablement
passionné par sa et qui ont chacun un
véritable petit arsenal est donc
effectivement ce sont des gens
extrêmement comment dire actif au niveau
haut niveau au niveau du lobbying est
donc là effectivement il ya une
difficulté
je pense je crois que c'est rsa serait
difficile de deux de venir à bout de
preuves comment dire que les lillois les
lois locales sont diverses effectivement
vous avez certains états comme la
californie très souple new york très
strict tout comme la caroline du nord où
si j'ose dire on peut se balader dans la
rue sans sans aucune difficulté avec des
armes en revanche ce qui est possible
que c'est le que dans le plan
d'investissement de byden il ya un volet
ya un volet social comme vous savez qui
serait dur jour au fur et à mesure que
le vote arrive mais il ya effectivement
tout un volet qui coûte qu'avec un
budget d'environ 6 milliards de dollars
courants sur huit en visant
comme non pas interdire le port d'armes
introduire des mesures de prévention du
genre l'éducation de la population
justice restaurative et c'est donc et le
thomas ap que tu as un procureur de
l'état de new york qui a lancé ce
programme et qui a été repris par baril
donnent donc dans sa campagne est très
content trouve que c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant cela dit comme
effectivement touché programme byden se
réduit de jour en jour nous serons au
moment du vote si ce volet là et
conserver ou non en janvier dernier le
washington post rapporté que certains
américains se retrouver vers les
magasins d'armement sur le premier mois
de l'année 2021 un pic de 80% par
rapport à janvier de l'année précédente
en cause 12h01 le washington post
l'arrivée de de bayda favorables à une
législation plus stricte sur les sur les
armes à feu ça dit quoi ça c'est dit que
c'est peu de nouveauté absolue que
c'était déjà la même chose avec obama
l'arrivée d'obama on a eu en 2008
intègre également d'un seul coup un pic
un pic sur sur les achats d'armes parce
qu'on sait très bien que en gros les
républicains sont le code de bagnères
enfin ils sont conservateurs donc et 10
épaules ce n'est pas le droit de porter
des armes qui est en question il suffit
de réprimer fortement ceux qui ceux qui
en font tellement un mauvais usage et
puis on sait bien que les démocrates
sont plus favorables réglementation donc
tout le reste douleur tous des
comportements si on en arrive à ce qu'on
dise au début de cette interview c'est
un problème qui n'en finira jamais aux
états unis et qui semble
aux etats unis
des limitations au niveau fédéral sont
possibles on peut imaginer que le droit
soit autorisée en principe et puis avec
de multiples limitation d'euros sur son
exercice un peu comme si on arrivait
pour l'avortement mais ces limitations
elle même supposer une majorité de 60 et
là comme vous savez avec commandites ou
quoi ça cause de la faible majorité de
britanniques et de certains démocrates
même si des cinémas qui sont les
véritables droits de washington
actuellement et qui bloque absolument
tout en tout cas voilà pour pour finir
un chiffre 1 486 morts par accident en
2019 états unis accident par arme à feu
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
lors ans et harry
et nous avons apporté votre éclairage